au moment où elle sera fatiguée elle va
avoir la possibilité de transformer son
rollator en fauteuil roulant pour une
maison plus inclusive la première
édition du salon itonomie habit se
tenait ce mardi 14 novembre à l'oxygène
Factory des Mureau service aide
technique ou financière plus de 40
exposants présentaient des solutions
pour un logement plus accessible pour
les personnes âgées vieillir à domicile
c'est mieux vieillir on voit du monde on
est plus actif et c'est une un des
maillons de notre nouvelle politique du
département des ibblines et des hautes
scènes avec le au travers de l'agence
autonomie privilégier le Bien vieillir à
domicile au détriment de la règle qui
voulait qu'on aille vieillir en épad en
France 90 % des personnes âgées
préfèrent adapter leur logement plutôt
qu'intégrer une maison de retraite selon
une enquête dispositif monte escalier ou
coussin releveur basé à trappe la
société axol propose du du matériel
d'accessibilité comme cette rampe
destinée au particulier on peut le
laisser en place toute la journée
c'està-dire que la seule chose qu'on a
faire c'est relever le volet pour fermer
fermer la baie vitrée on n pas obligé de
démonter l'ensemble compter environ 700
€ pour cet équipement facilitant les
déplacements du fauteuil vers les
terrasses ou les balcons des innovations
qui ont un coupt mais elles sont
éligibles à des soutiens du gouvernement
par exemple ma prime adapte qui va être
mise en place au mois de janvier qui
permet comme ma prime renove de
bénéficier d' financière pour pouvoir
adapter son logement c'està-dire
transformer une baignoire en douche et
CETA et ce bien vieillir chez soi un
défi important à relever le département
des ivelines est celui où la population
est la plus âgée en île-de-fance il
comptait 310000 seniors de plus de 60
ans en 2018 et Enat 450000 en